all that money everything that you're
going to accumulate in this life is
going to stay behind that's why we see
many wealthy athletes celebrities who
live like party lifestyles in the U.S
drinking clubs all of that you find them
leaving that or Ramadan for fasting or
wearing hijab or a conservative Islamic
lifestyle because they see that allowing
and worshiping your desires to bring
peace it brings misery but knowing your
lord is what brings peace in this life
and the next and that's why Islam
continues to be the fastest growing in
religion if you enjoyed this short clip
visit the dean show TV on YouTube to
watch the full video